whether we want to have a war in europe
or not of course we don't
and this is exactly the case why we have
preparedness
to have a
talks process the results of those talks
those
negotiations
should be an agreement on equal security
including our country
unfortunately and we have already
mentioned that there has been no
meaningful constructive response to our
proposals we haven't received them
we cannot
emphasize enough
how worried we are about a hundred
thousand troops along the border we
cannot see any reason why they should be
there because of that it is
essential that there is de-escalation
looking at the current difficult
situation it is important to make sure
there is no war in europe but during our
talks uh president putin um
reported about his talks with his
foreign secretary and uh with the
defense minister
we have not yet exhausted
diplomatic
solutions we need to make sure to work
towards a peaceful solution of the
conflict we've heard that some trips are
being with a drawn and that is a good
sign we hope more troops will be
withdrawn
well let's take a look then at the
latest developments and while the
russian president has been holding those
talks with the german chancellor in
moscow bros johnson held a cobra meeting
and is expected to travel to europe
later this week to step up the uk's
diplomatic efforts meanwhile there are
warnings of a humanitarian crisis with
ukrainian refugees going over the border
to places including poland this morning
russia's foreign minister sergey lavrov
has met his polish counterpart and it
comes as ukraine's president vladimir
zelinski declared tomorrow
a day of unity calling on ukrainians to
fly the country's flag and sing the
national anthem in unison
well here with me now security and
defense editor deborah haynes joining us
in kiev from south central ukraine
assessing the mood across the nation
here the focus there has been on moscow
uh what what came out of that news
conference we've heard in the last hour
well no breakthrough
worrying language really you had
president putin yes saying that he
doesn't want war but then also accusing
ukraine effectively of genocide in the
russia-backed separatist occupied
territories in the east which is
complete rubbish and is the sort of
language that western officials have
pointed to when they've been raising
their concerns about the potential for
russia to concoct some kind of crisis
that they can then say that they're
coming in to rescue um those russian
citizens in that area that they say need
their help and then that could be the
pretext for a much much larger invasion
and yes he did also say that he'd been
told didn't he about the you know
there's been a bit of a withdrawal of
some of the troops this massive build-up
of troops around the country some of
those russian troops had been withdrawn
but western officials are saying that on
balance they believe actually there's
been more reinforcing than
down and so well yes there was or there
is you know the hope that there could
still be a de-escalation and definitely
the german chancellor was very saying
you're inconceivable the idea of war in
europe again um and clearly the fact his
presence is in moscow he's only just a
couple of months into his term is
underlining that desperation that need
for european leaders to try to find some
way to to dial this down but there was
no obvious breakthrough from the meeting
from the press conference